[Musique]
mathé
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans tera ter
les missions qui vous donne envie d'agir
et de réagir en matière d'écologie le
tgv vient tout juste de fêter ses 40 ans
et à cette occasion le président
emmanuel macron a présenté le tgv du
futur plus rentable et moins gourmands
en énergie avec un nez aérodynamique qui
permet d'économiser 20% d'énergie le tgv
demain sera certainement plus écolo mais
le train dans son ensemble est ce le
transport écologique d'avenir alors que
80 % des trajets quotidiens se font
encore en voiture alors on s'interroge
le ferroviaire et il le pari gagnant du
désenclavement et de la compétitivité
voici d'abord les faits rien que les
faits avec ce teradata signée chloé
juhel
le train est mais cinquante fois moins
d'équivalent co2 que la voiture et 80
fois moins que l'avion
ce sont les chiffres dont se targue la
sncf à nuancer selon deux paramètres le
taux de remplissage du véhicule et la
distance parcourue
la france dispose du deuxième réseau
ferroviaire d'europe
il s'étend sur une longueur totale de
presque 27 milles 500 km
en moyenne plus de dix trains partent
toutes les minutes sur l'ensemble du
territoire
mais cela ne fait pas du train le mode
de transport préféré des français
la voiture arrive largement en tête plus
de 80% des déplacements à l'intérieur de
nos frontières se font à quatre roues
contre 7 % des trajets effectués
seulement sur les rails
le train et il le transport écolo
d'avenir
il ya donc une dynamique et un chemin
pour que le train concurrence la voiture
et participe au désenclavement des
territoires on va en parler avec
l'ancien ministre des transports
dominique bussereau qui est également
fils de cheminot c'est vous dire aussi
que ce dossier lui tient à coeur même si
vous n'avez plus aujourd'hui de mandat
électif bonjour dominique bussereau
bonjour et du mouchard fils et petit
fils fils et petit fils de cheminot
voilà pourquoi le train aussi fait
partie de votre vie le manuel maintenant
soulignait que le tgv était un peu le
graal pour les territoires est ce que
finalement depuis des décennies on n'en
fait pas trop autour du tgv est pas un
c'est autour du train en particulier
alors on a construit un réseau thé je
vais en france important et quand vous
construisez une ligne de tgv nouvelles
ont à prendre les derniers accros ont
été inaugurés tours bordeaux le mans
rennes va la bretagne vers le le sud de
la france vous dégager les lignes
classiques existantes qui ont parfois
des siècles et à ce moment là vous
permettez sur ses lignes de que circule
plus de ter non plus de trains du
quotidien mais également plus de trains
de fret donc moins de camions sur les
routes c'est important de le dire donc
le tgv a impulsé une bonne stratégie le
réseau ferroviaire de la france est le
deuxième réseau ferroviaire d'europe
nous avons 27 milles 500 km de voies
donc l état et le réseau les grandes
lignes classiques qui desservent des
grandes cités françaises par les fameux
train intercités sont en général de
bonne qualité où il ya des problèmes
parfois c'est sur les petites lignes
parce que pour des raisons financières
l'état et la sncf pendant longtemps ne
les ont pas bien entretenu et donc
aujourd'hui dans le cas des contrats de
plan ce sont des co financements de
l'état de sncf des régions des
départements des villes qui le font et
donc ça demande plus de temps et c'est
parfois plus compliqué parce que ces
lignes peuvent être parfois aussi
difficile d'accès dominique bussereau
vous n'êtes pas patron de la sncf mais
on a l'impression d'un manque
d'anticipation comment se fait-il qu'il
ya encore quelques années on annonçait
la fermeture de gares de ligne de
fermeture d être un nuit par exemple on
va on va et venir et qu'aujourd'hui même
cinq ans après bien on se rend compte
qu'on rechange de nouveaux logiciels car
on participe à l'état d'esprit du public
ça va être un grand homme du système
ferroviaire qui s'appelait louis armand
qu'elle est présente sncf qui disait si
le train survie au xxème siècle il
serait le mode d'avenir de 21e siècle
aujourd'hui le train a repris toute sa
pertinence
et on s'aperçoit qu'on a fait des
erreurs pourquoi la supprimer des trains
nuit passée plus personne dedans que
donc il était déficitaire sauf
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des gens des
françaises européens qui ne veulent plus
voyager en avion et qui ont envie de
tran huy à condition qu'ils soient
confortables climatisé sur secure est
donc un nouveau modèle y compris sur le
réseau secondaire soit présentée aux
clients vous avez fait vous même en tant
que ministre chargé des transports des
erreurs de stratégie d'anticipation
lorsque l'on parle du ferroviaire c'est
plus on n'a jamais mis l'accent à ces
sur le fret on a laissé la route prendre
trop d'importance on n'a pas non plus
d'ailleurs développé le fluvial et les
projets fluviaux ont été insuffisants
ces dernières années certainement on
aurait dû être plus volontariste sur le
fret mais là on sortait au fait que même
à l'intérieur de la sncf beaucoup ne
croyaient plus au fait tu reviens et
aujourd'hui on doit être en mesure comme
en suisse comme dans d'autres pays de
faire remonter le trafic de fret
investir dans le ferroviaire c'est donc
investir dans l'avenir très clairement
c'est celle à venir dans notre vie
quotidienne il faut investir sachant que
ça coûte très cher le train il n'y a pas
plus cher que le train parce que quand
on construit une ligne pour construire
une ligne il faut tenir compte de
l'environnement et donc le train est un
mode cher il faut l'accepter pour le
développement de nos sociétés alors on
va en parler dans le détail simplement
encore un mot du plan france relance qui
a été annoncé au mois de septembre par
le gouvernement 11 milliards et demi
d'euros alloués aux transports 4
milliards 700 millions d'euros dédiés au
secteur du ferroviaire c'est assez
d'argent pour qu'on veut en faire sur le
ferroviaire depuis jamais assez quand on
voit l'état de certaines de nos lignes
secondaires il faudrait peut-être le
double ou le triple et si déjà on peut
continuer à prolonger notre réseau tgv
si on peut continuer avec les régions et
les collectivités
à développer le transport ferroviaire de
proximité les transports dans les
grandes métropoles on aura fait déjà des
pas importants pour une meilleure
qualité de la vie dans notre pays alors
il ya la participation des politiques
des usagers consommateurs et puis il ya
la réalité je le disais 80 % des trajets
quotidiens se font en voiture
le concurrent direct du train reste donc
l'automobile dominique bussereau en
milieu urbain on voit bien que par
exemple 65 % des parisiens en plus de
voitures donc au milieu urbain quand il
ya une offre de transports publics plus
des taxis plus des vélos etc et de
qualité la voiture n'a plus sa
pertinence à la campagne c'est plus
compliqué parce que dans et j'étais
président du département de la
charente-maritime à 472 villages ou
villes et il ya vingt gares
donc il faut ensuite être capable alors
ça peut être par des cars par des bus
est peut-être demain par des véhicules
autonomes peut-être capable de maillé là
où il n'y a pas des ceintures aubière la
réalité du terrain est en pause et
dominique bussereau avec vous nous
allons débattre de cette question
d'importance le train transporte
d'avenir transport écologique d'avenir
pour joignons notre seconde invitée
l'état investit t'il assez est assez
bien dans le ferroviaire pour en faire
un transport durable et un transport
d'avenir dominique bussereau qui est
notre invité ancien secrétaire d'état
aux transports ah non débat désormais
avec notre seconde invitée valentin des
fontaines bonjour responsable mobilité
durable du réseau action climat france
et auteur du rapport transport
ferroviaire justement sommes-nous sur
les rails vous parlez de rails c'est ce
qu'ont investi comme il faut c'est
simple oui effectivement une
interrogation qui nourrit ce rapport
c'est de savoir si ces investissements
sont cohérents avec nos objectifs
climatiques puisque on a déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire le transport
ferroviaire c'est vraiment le mode de
transport peu polluant par excellence le
chiffre qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est
11 % des voyageurs 9 % des marchandises
pour seulement 0 3% des émissions du
secteur des transports qui est par
ailleurs le premier secteur émetteur de
gaz à effet de serre en france quand on
a investi dans le ferroviaire dominique
bussereau la dimension écologique
n'était pas la priorité il suffisait
d'aller vite et bien aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs on a conscience que le tgv de
demain n'y aura pas forcément plus vite
ce n'est - ce qui nous intéresse c'est
moins ce que nous recherchons les
problèmes sont anciens au 19e siècle on
a remplacé les diligences les voitures à
cheval par des trains mais il ya des
villes qui n'ont pas voulu les gars par
exemple tours orléans à bien ont refusé
la gare parce qu'ils avaient déjà peur à
l'époque de la pollution des locomotives
à vapeur à partir de la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale on est passé à
la diésélisation et l'a10 et lisa sion
ça paraissait déjà comme un progrès mais
aujourd'hui certains contestent le mode
diesel même s'il est encore très utilisé
souvent majoritaires un transport
ferroviaire et on est en train de
travailler sur des trains des
locomotives à hydrogène des trains
batteries rechargeables ou pas est donc
une évolution technologique qui améliore
à chaque fois la compétitivité
écologique du chemin de fer c'est ce que
vous voulez mettre en évidence aussi
avec votre rapport nos lacunes et nous
raisons d'y croire justement ce
ferroviaire plus écolo ouais
effectivement de rappeler peut-être que
pendant plusieurs années malheureusement
on a délaissé notamment les lignes du
quotidien ces fameuses petites lignes et
que maintenant il ya un vrai enjeu à
réinvestir aussi ses lignes là parce que
c'est en développant céline qu'on peut
proposer des alternatives efficaces à la
voiture notamment dominique bussereau
lui disait investir dans une ligne
ferroviaire investir dans le train ça
coûte cher ça coûte très cher l'argent
là les plans développés sont ils à la
hauteur de nos ambitions et des
exigences des usagers aujourd'hui on
estime qu'il faut environ trois
milliards d'euros supplémentaires par an
en au moins 10 années
si on veut se remettre sur ces fameux
rails et et tenir nos objectifs
climatiques ces trois milliards d'euros
ils sont globalement répartis pour
moitié sur le transport de voyageurs et
puis pour une deuxième moitié sur le
transport de marchandises est-ce que
l'ouverture à la concurrence de la sncf
peut changer la donne justement cet
investissement elle a déjà changé la
donne parce que même si comme le
rappelait notre ami le transport de fret
faible 1 9% rim de transport de
marchandises en france la moitié déjà
fait part des entreprises privées dont
d'ailleurs dit filiale de la sncf qui se
sont révélés plus compétitive que leur
maison mère donc ça veut dire que ça
ailleurs si on n'avait pas fait cette
ouverture européenne du fret on en
serait encore bien en-deça de 9% les
allemands ont fait ça bien avant nous et
donc les allemands arrivent aujourd'hui
un taux d'occupation de leurs trains
régionaux qui est à peu près le double
en moyenne de celui qui existe en france
un coût pour le contribuable parce que
quand vous prenez atr est quasiment rien
c'est le contribuable de votre région y
compris en ile de france qu'il paye ou
les entreprises en ile de france et donc
l'objectif c'est grâce à la
régionalisation à l'ouverture à la
concurrence d'avoir plus de trains et
d'avoir également un coût moins
important pour le contrer la plus de
qualité et moins d'argent c'est quand
même pas mal c'est pas mal oui parce que
c'est bien ça le problème le coût pour
l'usager et puis la rentabilité on va
prendre un exemple sur les trains de
nuit qui transportait en france en 1981
environ 10 millions de personnes en 2013
c'était un million deux cent mille
personnes voilà pourquoi on les a fermés
que le gouvernement d'aujourd'hui
envisage de les rouvrir
là il faut miser par exemple sur ce
train de nuit qui peut permettre de
lutter contre le sur tourisme
d'économiser une nuit d'hôtel il ya
aussi des raisons pratiques touristiques
qui peuvent militer pour cela oui
effectivement il faut il faut miser sur
sur l'autre à nu puisque le train de
nuit c'est notamment une très bonne
alternative à l'avion parce que on prend
le train tard le soir et puis on arrive
tôt le matin à destination et
insuffisamment investi sur sur le réseau
ce qui entraîne des ralentissements et
on connaît bien malheureusement ce cycle
on a d'abord des ralentissements donc
les gens délaissent le train et puis
ensuite il ya moins de monde dans le
train et donc la ligne finit par fermer
par exemple sur le saint-etienne
clermont-ferrand ont aujourd'hui plus
trains à cause de ces ralentissements et
qu'il ya le problème du matériel roulant
donc d'être un ami henry en eux mêmes
qui sont âgés ont ils ont plus de 40 ans
aujourd'hui on n'a pas su les
redévelopper attend les régénérer dont
il faut aussi s'adapter et proposer des
trains nuit de meilleur standing parce
qu'on n'y a pas cru dominique besoin il
faut redonner du plaisir aux trains de
nuit le plaisir d'arriver par exemple au
petit matin à venise et à la gare de
venise ont des devant le grand canal et
là on est émerveillé alors ce que n'est
pas le cas lorsqu'on arrive à les
reports de l'insae ligne est suspendu
c'est intéressant ce que dit dominique
bussereau en redonner le plaisir du
train alors on va parler après du de la
réalité avec le prix parfois exorbitants
et rébarbative des billets pratiqués par
la sncf mais ce plaisir du train on l'a
perdue c'est ce que souligne aussi votre
rapport qu'on vous interroger si nous
sommes sur les rails dans le ferroviaire
alors les gens vont pas vers lui ce qui
a priori hier une vraie volonté
justement à prendre d'avancé relevé
train et on a notamment faire une étude
au niveau européen et les chiffres
étaient assez clair il y avait environ
sept sondés sur dix sept européens sur
dix qui se disaient favorables à prendre
davantage le train et quand on parle
notamment des trains européens c'est
encore plus flagrant c'est très
compliqué de se rendre à rome de se
rendre à madrid à lisbonne pourtant
assez proche du territoire français donc
on n'est plus face à un problème d'offre
qu'un leurre est un problème d'autres
demandent aujourd'hui alors messieurs le
train transport dans lequel nous avons
envie de croire transport le plus propre
ça on l'a dit mais alors on voulait vous
mettre en garde sur un coût
environnemental cachée du train il faut
juste savoir c'est l'impact notamment de
la construction des lignes à grande
vitesse sur les milieux naturels
juliette jean s'est donc rendu le long
de la ligne tours-bordeaux une ligne
gérée par le concessionnaire lisea la
propriété de vinci et qui doit compenser
les effets de la ligne c'est à dire
rendre à la nature en quelque sorte qui
a été détruit beaucoup de choses sont
faites en la matière regardez
[Musique]
ici il ya encore quelques années vivait
paisiblement des grenouilles et des
tritons mais depuis l'arrivée du train
les amphibiens ont dû faire leurs
valises lors de la construction de cette
ligne tours bordeaux il a fallu mettre
en place des mesures dites
compensatoires en bref si l'on détruit
l'habitat d'une espèce protégée on doit
recréer à proximité cet habitat sur des
surfaces deux fois voire trois fois plus
grande sur cette ligne 223 espèces
protégées sont impactés comme ici aux
abords de la boivre une rivière qui
passe par la ville de poitiers on a fait
des travaux de génie hydraulique qui
sont des mesures de compensation à
destination du brochet est en général de
toute la faune piscicole ici on est sur
un site où il y avait un espèce de
barrage qui coupait la rivière en deux
et ainsi on a rejointe et si je puis
dire
les deux bouts du cours d'eau et on
offre un cours d'une continuité
écologique beaucoup plus importante pour
le brochet en particulier mais aussi
pour toute la faune piscicole du cours
d'eau sur l'ensemble de la ligne pour
compenser la destruction de la nature
3800 hectares ont été restaurés
maintenant l'étape c'est le suivi des
mesures mises en place un travail qui
s'inscrit dans le temps long notre
objectif c'est d'avoir un projet à la
biodiversité positive à terme on voit
qu'il ya des sites de milieux naturels
qui sont en permanence conquis soit par
l'agriculture soit par
l'artificialisation des terres l'ale
d'extension des agglomérations avec ces
mesures compensatoires que l'on
entretient pendant 40 ans on est sûr que
ces sites sont favorables à la
biodiversité skierai pas forcément été
le cas s'il ce programme n'existe pas
une position nuancée par les
associations de protection de
l'environnement qui dénoncent des
mesures parfois aléatoire est trop
optimiste
si des mares ont été créés pour
accueillir nos amphibiens déloger
on s'aperçoit que pour le moment on
retrouve un petit peu la diversité ça
qu'on retrouve quasiment les espèces qui
étaient bien qu'ils avaient été
inventoriés initialement mais par contre
en terme de quantité on est très très
très loin encore du conte va falloir
beaucoup de temps pour que les
populations
initialement présentes sur le secteur
puisse
s'installer à nouveau et perdurer mais
il faut ajouter à cela des ouvrages
parfois surprenants ici on a créé ces
tunnels passant sous la voie pour
permettre aux amphibiens de traverser
sans danger si certains animaux ont
compris le principe ils utilisent ce ne
sont pas être le cas des grenouilles
malgré tout l'ensemble de ces mesures
compensatoires ont été validés par
l'état en novembre 2020 mais les
négociations ont été complexes des fois
ce n'était pas pas toujours pas toujours
évident parce qu'il y avait aussi la
pression du du porteur de projet pour
faire en sorte que ça aille rapidement
que con que la compensation soit évalué
aux manières de manière minime
minimaliste parce que forcément il ya
des enjeux économiques derrière la mise
en place des mesures compensatoires
c'est aussi un leurre dans le sens où tu
as compensation
avec 1
un résultat zéro impact sur la
biodiversité
ça n'existe pas quoi
[Musique]
voilà son reportage de juliette gens je
vous fait réagir dominique bussereau
parce que vous connaissez ce coût
environnemental mais aussi les efforts
fournis par les associations on l'a vu
et par les concessionnaires des efforts
d'ampleur pour préserver c'est de
s'occuper au gouvernement de la
construction cette line riz dans
certains secteurs ce à améliorer
l'environnement dire qu'on est passé de
2,2 l'an de dégoûtante mal entretenu un
passage en toute qualité avec une
reforestation met de côté parfois très
loin des passages pour le gibier et
honnêtement la blessure dans le paysage
d'une ligne tgv c'est beaucoup moins
qu'une ligne à haute tension c'est moins
certaines éoliennes et c'est beaucoup
moins qu'une autoroute c'est un c'est
pas si facile que ça quand vous lirez
ouvrir et d'autoroutes ferroviaires mais
des camions sur des wagons et pour
empêcher les camions sur la route heures
mais avec des communes qui disent non on
veut pas parce que nos passages à
niveaux vont être fermés toute la
journée on n'en veut pas la réouverture
ou l'accélération du trafic sur une
ligne ferroviaire pose aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de difficultés une des
composantes que vous avez eu à affronter
lorsque vous rédigez votre rapport aux
6,1 effectivement je vous l'avais déjà
dire le réseau français il fait près de
29 mille kilomètres on tient un vrai
enjeu aussi à commencer par redévelopper
le train sur le réseau existant ce qu'on
a la chance d'avoir un réseau très dense
on sait par exemple qu on a environ 9
français sur 10 qui habitent à moins de
10 kilomètres d'une gare qu'on a déjà un
réseau qui est densément maillet je me
permet de rebondir sur un autre point
quel est l'impact climatique de ces
constructions de ligne là il ya des
exemples intéressants notamment sur
dijon belfort il ya des études
évidemment qu'on était fait on pour
évaluer l'impact climatique de cette
nouvelle ligne lgv est ce que l'on
constate c'est que le train est
tellement peu émetteurs par rapport aux
autres modes de transport que finalement
l'impact climatique de cette ligne il a
été amorti en environ douze années ça
montre encore une fois que le train il
est vraiment moins émetteur et puis
surtout ça pose une question presque
philosophie j'ai envie de dire à savoir
où est ce qu'on met notre nos émissions
de carbone puisque on sait qu'on va être
limité en termes d'émissions de carbone
est ce qu'on le met dans des
infrastructures qui vont durer quarante
années qui vont servir pour de la lgv
mais pas qu'eux qui peuvent aussi pour
des trains de nuit pourquoi pas pour du
fret où est-ce qu'on le met dans des
avions court courrier qui volent 1h20 et
puis ensuite c'est terminé sa pose aussi
ces questions là c'est toute cette
philosophie du train que nous prônons
dans cette émission avec nos invités
pour l'illustrer et que ne démentira pas
notre invité dans ce tous terre à terre
elle publie un ouvrage intitulé ce lot
xiii voilà à prendre justement à ré
envisager le train comme une découverte
douce et lente de territoire
et le voici le livre de notre invité
juliette la baronne dans ce tous
terre-à-terre bonjour juliette votre
livre est un guide qui raconte les
histoires de ligne les histoires des
territoires une déclaration d'amour au
train à la gare aux territoires aussi le
train qui ré enchante le territoire 40
ans de tgv ont vraiment façonner les
des imaginaires l'idée c'était de parler
aussi des petites lignes de celle qui
passe dans tous les villages qui sont
pas forcément dans des lgv mais qui
vraiment passe à côté des maisons dans
les tous les paysages de la paix qui
sont extrêmement variés et l'idée était
prendre ces trains du quotidien de les
prendre à rebrousse poil finalement de
façon touristique oui de joigny à
paimpol ou de clermont ferrand à nîmes
on va prendre cet itinéraire un
magnifique épisodes cévenols par exemple
alors autour de 2,5 heures de train
c'est tout près de chez vous en faites
vous avez voulu aussi vous appuyez sur
le maillage qui existant en région pour
donner envie aux habitants de
redécouvrir leur territoire à leur
patrimoine absolument l'idéal était en
fait on peut se dépayser à deux pas de
chez soi et on peut se dépayser en
prenons un moyen de transport finalement
conscient qu'il ya 150 ans et l'idée de
le ré enchanter vraiment ce cévenol
qu'on appelle voilà ce train qui va être
clermont ferrand à anime passe d'abord
au sud de l'auvergne et ensuite dans
toutes les cévennes et ils traversent
des territoires fantastique on a
l'impression parfois d'être au canada et
il ya des zones où ils traversent des
endroits où en fait il n'ya pas
d'habitations pas de routes non plus
donc qui permet d'avoir des aperçus de
territoire pour ne pas voir contre on
peut aussi alterner avec de la randonnée
à pied ou à vélo puisque c'est vrai que
le transport permet une grande muette
modalités ont pensé aussi à ce pas de
côté privilégier le train régional le
train de proximité alors c'est celui où
il n'ya pas de ya pas de prise forcément
y'a pas de wifi forcément mais c'est
aussi cet éloge du train avant que vous
mettez un petit peu en avant oui alors
j'avais envie de parler de ces petites
lignes parce qu'elles ont été souvent
montrés du doigt comme étant coûteuse
voire d'arrière garde moi j'ai emprunté
ses trains et de façon touristique mais
c'est également des lignes de vie qui
sont très importantes pour pour les
habitants qui sont dans ces territoires
il faut penser que tout le monde n'a pas
les moyens d'avoir une voiture tout le
monde ne peut pas conduire l'état dé
certaines personnes âgées ont parlé du
cévenol les routes sont extrêmement
verglacée l'hiver il ya des lycéens des
personnes qui n'ont pas encore l'âge de
conduire et le train ce patrimoine
hérité de nos ancêtres et qui a été
vraiment construit à coups de marteau il
faut quand même se rendre compte qu'il
ya des tunnels qui ont été faits dans
les montagnes dans des conditions
incroyables au 19e siècle qu'il faut le
l'entretenir il faut lui rendre hommage
et il faut aussi se rendre compte que
voilà on a besoin de maintenir ces
lignes l'idée avec ce livre c'était de
commencer à prendre par la main les
personnes pour les guider un peu au
début leur raconter un peu l'histoire et
après ils feront leur propre voyage
autour leur propre étape bravo vous avez
dû faire parce que vous avez rédigé ce
livre avant l'épisode qu'ovide qui nous
a poussés justement à redécouvrir les
trésors de proximité à au sortir de la
maison alors on nous disait c'est un
guide c'est aussi un petit peu votre
philosophie manifeste aussi du train et
de la lenteur du train pour redécouvrir
la france notre france selon trend chez
arthaud merci beaucoup plus liette le
lac du secret du coeur et ce guide
formidable
voilà qu'on se livre entre guider et
manifeste qui nous propose une trentaine
d'échappée ferroviaire cela vous fait
réagir dominique bussereau car en dehors
de tout votre itinéraire d'hommes
politiques vous occupez aujourd'hui de
train touristique lettre un touriste et
que je formule 1 n'existe plus de 90 en
france sont gérés par des associations
par des collectivités par les
entreprises moi je m'occupe de deux
d'entre eux l'unc et le train des
mouettes alors c'est une ancienne ligne
qui suit un fleuve côtier là ce droit en
charente-maritime et qui va de saujon
près de royan à la tremblade quasiment
jusqu'à l'océan oui traversant les
anciens marais salants et cetera avec
des locomotives à vapeur dans certaines
sont classées monuments historiques la
plus ancienne à 130 ans ils se sont
souvent des objets patrimoniaux bien sûr
ce sont des trains d'histoire qu'il ne
roule pas à l'hydrogène l'air non il
roule roule à la vapeur qui fait parfois
râler alors du train passion au train
innovations qui nous intéresse aussi va
longtemps des fontaines le train à
hydrogène tenez en à l'acf clients de
passer commande à alstom des 12 premiers
trains à hydrogène français ce sont des
technologies d'avenir mais c'est
l'avenir pour vous de ce train
insisterait peut-être sur un point
l'hydrogène vers ça veut dire de
l'hydrogène qui produirait des énergies
renouvelables ce qui veut aussi dire
qu'on n'aura pas d'hydrogène pour tous
les modes de transport pour tous les
usages et en ce moment on parle beaucoup
d'hydrogène on en parle pour beaucoup de
choses à l'hydrogène l'enjeu c'est de le
mettre là où on n'a pas tellement
d'alternative par exemple dans le
transport maritime on sait qu'on a on
est de limiter sur les alternatives ça
peut être une bonne solution sur le
transport routier pour certains
véhicules ça peut être aussi une
solution ça peut l'être aussi pour le
tram et c'est une technologie coûte cher
mais attention à ce que ça ne se fasse
pas au détriment de l'investissement
notamment dans le réseau et puis à
d'autres solutions notamment les trains
bi-mode donc les trains bi-mode sont des
trains en fait avec des batteries 1 et
donc par moments on roule sur le réseau
électrique classique
et puis quand ya pas de caténaires et
ben on va rouler sur les batteries et ça
c'est très intéressant ce camp est ça
permet de réduire considérablement le
coût de l'électrification du réseau bien
compris cette secondaires par rapport
aux maillages qu'il nous faut densifier
aujourd'hui et sur une céline du
quotidien sur lequel insiste votre
rapport le fils et petit fils de
cheminot que vous êtes dominique
bussereau est plutôt optimiste
demande sur la vertu du train le chemin
de fer est vraiment au coeur du 21e
siècle simplement il faut le financer ça
passe par le fait que les clients
acceptent de payer quand même un prix
convenable il faut aussi parfois un
financement des entreprises et un
financement des collectivités l'état n'y
arrivera jamais donc les régions les
départements les collectivités tout le
monde doit participer au financement il
faut aussi que l'état de dessert un peu
la bride à nous les collectivités pour
qu'on puisse en dégager encore plus
d'argent pour développer les transports
publics ont plusieurs porteuse d'espoir
merci dominique bussereau merci valentin
des fontaines alors je vais vous
signaler trois livres le premier que
nous évoquions dans ce tous terre à
terre selon trend cet éloge de la
lenteur par le train 30 cinéraire pour
voyager autrement en train voilà aussi
de circonstance pour parcourir l'europe
confortablement installés aussi le
paysage défilant par la fenêtre celui
qui nous a évoqué il ya quelques
instants avec les trains touristiques
dominique bussereau et puis alors là
c'est là c'est l'histoire en marche
l'orient-express et compagnie livre de
photos livres d'histoire voilà en
réalité il ya assez peu de livres sur le
train de demain donc à nous décrire les
pages de ce transport d'avenir merci
beaucoup à vous tous d'avoir suivi cette
émission sur le train de transport de
demain merci au comptoir général près du
canal saint martin à paris de nous
accueillir ce lieu est aussi porteur des
valeurs que nous mettons en avant
régulièrement dans notre émission
terre-à-terre émission s'est tourné en
partie avec des smartphones alors on
applaudit la technologie se sont aussi
matériels extrêmement polluant qu'ils
font aux cycles et merci de votre
d'élite et merci nous accompagne
régulièrement dans cette émission qui
est la vôtre merci
[Musique]